- [Atari] Eight pork products crammed into one
huge pork patty.
^- What's up internet, I'm the sauce boss
^from Epic Meal Time.
^I'm here with my boy.
^- Chef Atari.
Today we're going to be baking
the power pork patty,
but a little toned down, scaled down version
that you can make in your home, in your small ovens.
And we didn't stop there,
we bacon wrapped that, in a bacon weave.
- [Harley] Let's make it happen.
So the power pork patty's special because
when you're constantly thinking up recipes,
we always have to reach into the deepest,
darkest corners of what could be, or should be a meal.
- [Atari] Everybody's always like, oh my god,
I must eat an epic meal, oh my god.
Then you put them in front of an epic meal,
they don't even know what to do with it,
like they don't even know their first bite,
or how to even approach it,
and it's like exactly.
People sometimes just get a little scared,
or a little shocked at how big
these larger than life meals are.
- [Harley] Epic Meal Time's always been about innovation
and, I saw in the Food Game, there are just lots of meals
that can be taken to the next level,
that weren't being taken to the next level.
Whenever I have a crazy idea,
I go up to Atari and I'm like,
let's make it happen.
He's like, it sounds impossible,
and I'm like well, that's your job.
And he makes it happen, he makes the impossible possible.
- [Atari] We call ourselves Google chefs.
We see it, we look at it,
and we multiply the hell out of it.
So my role on Epic Meal Time
is bacon manipulation, transformation engineer.
- [Harley] Once we first started out,
it was just like we were just joking around,
and having a good time, but then there were,
you know, leading minds in the culinary world
looking to us to see what we were doing.
We have now become the forefront
of ridiculous neo concepts.
- [Akira] Being a guerrilla chef, cooking unconventionally,
is the science, there's never really
a right or wrong way to cook, so just go for it.
I never thought I'd be cooking an ostrich egg
on the side of Arnold Schwarzenegger's tank.
We made the steak and egger sandwich,
steak and egger.
- [Harley] Pure pork deliciousness.
There's like a personal pork patty.
It's too powerful.
You've got that sweetness from the ham in there,
saltiness from the sausage, mmm.
- Yep, that's a mini power pork patty.
- Feels delicious in my power pork palate.
- [Atari] Oh yes.
(epic music)